「実践で学ぶ量子コンピューティング」へようこそ、ホストのOlivia Lanesだ。前回は
Max Cutと呼ばれる最適化問題へのQuantum Computingアプローチをqubo定式化を使って解説した。
かなり深く掘り下げたが、あくまで一つのアプローチの一例に過ぎない。今日は近期応用について
より広く取り上げ、有用なQuantum解が見つかりそうな問題の種類への直感を養い、
コミュニティでutility
スケールで達成された重要な研究の最近の例も見ていく。以前、すべての問題が追加の計算能力を必要とするわけではないと簡単に触れた。
特にQuantum Computingを使わなくても効率的に解けるものもある。それらはすでに皆が一番
馴染みのある問題だ——算術、SNSのスクロール、テトリスやDoomなどのビデオゲームなど。これらは大まかに
「簡単な問題」とみなされる。一方で、非常に難しい問題もある。例えば巨大な
整数の素因数分解がそれで、RSA暗号の基盤であり、Shorのアルゴリズムが実際に解くために設計されたものだ。もう一つの
例は、ソートされていないデータセットから解を見つけることだ。これは理論上、Groverのアルゴリズムとして知られるquantum algorithmで解ける。
しかし、ほとんどの専門家はこうした種類のアルゴリズムには誤り訂正の
実装が必要であり、技術的にはまだそこに到達していないと認識している。だからこの
レッスンと量子学習の旅を進める中で、覚えておいてほしい——私たちが探しているのは、ちょうどここ真ん中にある甘い地点だ。
解くのは難しい問題だ。でもそれがまた面白い所でもある。まだあまり触れていないことの一つが
計算複雑性理論だ。理由の一つは、やや難しく感じられるからで、そう、
複雑だ。計算複雑性理論とは、計算問題を
どれだけ難しいかによって分類することを目指すコンピュータサイエンスの分野だ。古典的コンピューティングには大量の複雑性クラスがあるが、最も
基本的なのはP問題だ。これは問題の規模が大きくなっても多項式時間で解けるものを指す。
つまり解くのが簡単な問題だ。次のより難しい種類はNP問題で、
非決定性多項式の略だ。これらは答えの検証は多項式時間でできるが、必ずしも
解けるとは限らない問題だ。次はNP完全で、既知の多項式解がない本当に難しい問題になってくる。
ここに巡回セールスマン問題や、ゲームの
数独が属している。さて、Quantum Computingが登場した際——少なくとも理論上は——人々はかなりの労力をかけて
この新しいタイプのコンピュータが効率的に解ける問題のクラスを特定しようとした。新たな
問題クラスが考案された。それが有界誤り量子多項式問題、略してBQPだ。厳密な定義は
少し長いが、quantum computerが多項式時間で、わずかな
誤りの可能性とともに解けるdecision Problemのクラスだ。誤りの可能性があるのはquantum measurementが本質的にランダムだからだが、
誤りの確率は任意に小さくできる。これらのクラスはすべて、PSPACEと呼ぶより大きなクラスの中にあり、そこに
BQPが他のすべての問題タイプと比べてどこに位置するかが分かる。ただし、これを
数学的に確実に証明するのは非常に難しい。BQPのQuantum問題はNP完全問題と必ずしも重ならないことに気づくだろう。
しかし、NP完全問題を解こうとするQuantum Computingのアプローチを見たことがある人もいるだろう。なぜ
そうなのか？よくある誤解の一つは、quantum computerに対して
巡回セールスマン問題などのNP完全問題の解を探求する意味はないというものだ。あるいは任意の問題、
またはQuantumのスピードアップの数学的証明が見つかっていないということで。しかし、必ずしもそうである必要はない。
quantum algorithmがその古典的対応物より速いという数学的証明を見つけることは稀だ。ShorとGroverは
これまでのところそれが達成されたわずかな例のうちの二つに過ぎない。しかしそれで構わない。実際、コンピュータ
科学者たちはPクラスとNPクラスが異なることすら証明できていない——あらゆる直感が
そうであるはずだと言っているにもかかわらず。また、二つのアルゴリズムを比較してそのスケールを見る場合、多くは最悪の場合の
シナリオを見る。実際には最悪のケースが現実に現れないことは十分ありうる。だから
落ち込む必要はない。代わりにヒューリスティック解法というアイデアを導入する。もし
実験主義者なら、こうした種類の解法はすでに知っていて気に入っているだろう。ヒューリスティックとは、
実用的ではあるが必ずしも最適ではない問題解決へのアプローチのことだ。それで十分だ。なぜなら解法は最適でなくても
非常に有用な場合がある。例えば、金融アプリケーションを考えてみよう。Quantumが活用できそうなほとんどのFinancialアルゴリズムに対し、まだ
指数的なスピードアップは見つかっていない。しかし、それは必ずしも問題じゃない——最適な解は必要ない。
少なくとも金融においては、1%でも効率が上がる解であれば数十億ドル規模の
利益に匹敵しうるからだ。では、今まさにQuantum Computingに適したユースケースや問題をどう見極めるか、そして「今まさに」というのは
Quantum utilityあるいはAdvantageが今もしくは
それほど遠くない将来に見つかるかなり有力な理由があるという意味だ。まず問題が絶対に持つべきでないことを挙げた方が早いかもしれない。
膨大な数のqubitを必要とするのはダメだ。数千〜数百万のqubitが使えるプロセッサはまだない。それがShorsの
algorithmなどがまだ遠い先の話である主な理由の一つだ。circuitも信じられないほど深くなってはいけない。
どのcircuit depthがうまくいかないかを正確に言うのは難しい。非常に多くの要因に依存するからだ。しかし一般的に、
実験で必要なdepthが文献でまだ達成されていない場合、苦労することになるかもしれない。
最後に、誤り訂正が必要だと分かっている種類のアルゴリズムはまだ実行できない。ただし、探すべきものは、特定のQPU上で
利用可能なqubitのほとんどを活用する実験だ。誤りの軽減と抑制の
重要性も強調してきた。そして最後に、社会にとって重要な将来の
アプリケーションへの明確な拡張性があり、最終的にQuantum
Advantageにつながる可能性が見えるものでなければならない。では、三つの主要カテゴリに分類されるユースケースの例について話そう。
近期から中期にかけて有利な結果が得られる可能性が最も高いと
特定した三つのカテゴリだ。最初の分野は自然のシミュレーションだ。以前にも触れた。
quantum computerが分子・原子レベルで行われている研究を向上させる機会は非常に多い。
この理由は、現在の古典的な手法が根本的に非効率な数学的
原子構造の記述によって制限されているからだ。量子状態を保存・操作するには指数関数的なリソースが必要で、
古典コンピューターではそれが必要だが、量子コンピューターなら効率的に処理できる。これが材料シミュレーションを
最も有望な応用分野の一つにしている理由だ。さらに具体的には、これが
二酸化炭素の固定技術、次世代バッテリー、あるいは新薬の発明につながる可能性がある。
この分野で特に関連性の高いアルゴリズムとして、変分量子固有値ソルバー（VQE）があり、これは
材料の平衡状態や最小エネルギー状態などの特定の特性を推定するのに使われる。別の例として
時間ダイナミクスシミュレーション（TDS）があり、そのアルゴリズムは材料の応答関数やスペクトル特性を推定するのに使われる。
それから、新参者のサンプルベース量子対角化についても触れておきたい。近い将来、これについて
もっと多くを耳にすることになると思う。次の応用分野は最適化だ。最適化はコンピューティングにおいて非常に
広範囲にわたるものなので、ユースケースはかなり多様だ。
ただし、よく聞く例としては、金融におけるポートフォリオ最適化、工業設計、そして
物流とサプライチェーンがある。最適化に関連してよく耳にする最も一般的なアルゴリズムは、すでに
ある程度詳しく取り上げた量子近似最適化アルゴリズム、すなわち
QAOAだ。最後に、ここ数年で大きな注目を集めている分野が量子機械学習だ。
QMLがシミュレーションほど早く実現しないのは明らかだと思うが、それでも
研究者たちが継続的に取り組んでいる印象的なアルゴリズムがあり、非常に重要なユース
ケースに対応している。考えられるユースケースには、自然言語処理、ネットワークトラフィック解析、さらには
金融取引における不正検出などがある。この分野の関連アルゴリズムとしては、量子サポートベクター
マシン、量子ニューラルネットワーク、量子生成的敵対ネットワークがある。これら三つの
グループは広範な応用分野であることを明確にしておきたい。また、コミュニティにおいては
特定のトピックに焦点を当てたグループが共同で取り組むことにも利点がある。IBMはそれほど昔ではない頃に
ワーキンググループと呼ばれるイニシアチブを立ち上げ、四つの特定の分野でコラボレーターが出会い、生産的な相乗効果を生み出せるよう
支援しようとした。その分野とは、ヘルスケアとライフサイエンス、材料とHPC、高エネルギー物理学、そして
最適化だ。現在のグループとそれらの取り組みに関わる組織を紹介しよう。ワーキンググループの活動について詳しく知りたければ、
説明欄に四つのホワイトペーパーを添付してある。さっき言ったように、
このコースのこの時点でやるべき最善のことは、人々が取り組んでいる問題の種類を探求し、最先端で
どんなアルゴリズムが機能するかを知るための直観を養うことだと思う。
始める前に、ここで主な目標は実験の
細部を全て理解することではないとはっきりさせておきたい。この種の分析は、論文が自分の専門分野から少し外れている場合、専門家でさえ非常に
難しいと感じることがある。目標は単純に、量子コンピューターが得意な問題の種類についての直観を養い、
どう対処するかを学ぶことだ。もし細かい部分に興味があって、これが何か
アイデアを刺激したなら、ぜひ論文本体を読んでほしい。取り上げる具体的なユースケースと
論文はこれらだ。まず、ハドロンダイナミクスのシミュレーションを論じた論文を探求する。
これは高エネルギー物理学のカテゴリーに該当する。次に最適化問題、
具体的にはバイアスフィールド対抗断熱量子最適化を取り上げる。そして最後に、もう一つ
別のシミュレーション問題を見るが、今度はmRNA、つまり
医薬品と治療薬開発にとって重要な分子に焦点を当てる。これらの論文に詳しくても詳しくなくても問題ない。
三つ全てを順に解説していく。どれも実質的な規模の問題に取り組んだ重要な論文であり、量子
コンピューターが科学的探究のもう一つの手法として使われ始めていることを示している。最初はハドロン
ダイナミクスのシミュレーションだ。ワシントン大学のMartin Savageのグループによる論文を詳しく見ていく。タイトルは
「112 qubitを使用したシュウィンガーモデルにおけるハドロンダイナミクスの量子
シミュレーション」だ。高エネルギー物理学者でなくても、ハドロンという言葉には聞き覚えがあるかもしれない。
例えば、大型ハドロン衝突型加速器（LHC）は、円周27キロメートルの巨大な粒子加速器で、
ついにヒッグス粒子の観測を可能にした。ハドロンとは、他のより小さな
クォークと呼ばれる粒子で構成された亜原子複合粒子だ。例えば中性子や陽子がある。少し背景として、LHCは
基本的な物理現象、つまり超高エネルギーで粒子が衝突したときに何が起こるかを研究するために建設された。
この円形チューブの中でそれを行うことで、科学者たちは初期宇宙がどのように誕生したかをより深く理解しようとしている。
また先ほど述べたように、素粒子の質量を担う捉えにくい粒子である粒子の発見にも使われた。
原理的には、これらの粒子の相互作用は
十分に強力な量子コンピューターで最初から最後までシミュレートできるはずだ。まだそこには到達していないが、進歩は
続いている。シュウィンガーモデルはこれらのダイナミクスの一部をシミュレートするための単純なモデルで、最も
よく選ばれるモデルの一つとなっている。モデルの細部は今はそれほど重要ではないが、興味がある人のために言うと、
それは1+1次元で光子を介して相互作用する電子と陽電子の振る舞いを記述するモデルだ。
つまり、一つの空間次元と時間がある。このモデルは量子
色力学（QCD）と多くの類似点があり、QCDはクォークとハドロンがどのように相互作用するかを記述する。シミュレートするのが極めて難しいので、
シュウィンガーモデルは、実際に両方に共通するいくつかの現象を調べるためのおもちゃモデルとしてよく使われる。
さて、この例と残りの例をどのように進めるかだが、
一連の質問を自分たちに問いかけていく。最初の質問は、なぜ量子コンピューターでこれをシミュレートすることが
うまくいくと考える理由があったのかだ。この場合、シュウィンガーモデルの電子と陽電子にはスクリーニング効果があり、
遠く離れたフォノン間の相関が分離とともに指数関数的に減衰する原因となっている。これは
チップの片側のqubitからもう片側のqubitへの長距離相互作用がそれほど多くないことを意味する。
非常にエラーが起きやすいことはわかってるから、これは今日使えるハードウェアにとって本当に重要だ。次は
このトピックが興味深いかどうかだが、高エネルギー物理学が非常に重要だということはもう納得してもらえたと思う。
LHCを建設するために何十億ドルもの費用をかけ、世界中の何千人もの科学者や
技術者がこの分野に人生を捧げている。それほど重要な分野だ。しかし
シュリンガーモデルは単純化されており、3つの空間次元をカバーするように設計されていない。それでも
このモデルは重要だ。現時点でテスト可能な断面や完全な理論の有用な単純化を提供しているからだ。
最後に、この研究はどのように行われたか、あるいはシミュレーション型実験で研究を継続しようとする場合どのようなアプローチを使うかだが、
vqeが最も一般的なアプローチの一つで、最初のステップはほぼ常に同じだ。
基底状態を準備する。この場合は真空状態だ。この実験ではSCと呼ばれるvqeの新バージョンを使用した。
adapt vqeで真空上の基底状態とハドロン波束の両方を準備する。次のステップは
ハドロンが時間的に発展または伝播できるようにすることだ。最後に、検出したい
観測量を特定する必要がある。これらのステップがどこか聞いたことがある気がするなら、ハドロン波束の
部分を除いて、それは前のエピソードのqaoaの例で扱った内容と非常に似ているからだ。
ここでいくつかのパターンが見えてきたと思う。vqeに必要なコンポーネントはqaoaと非常に似ている。
おなじみの状態、ここでは真空状態から始め、指数化された一連の
ハミルトニアンで時間発展させる。nが分割数で、管理しやすいチャンクに分けられている。ここでの唯一の大きな違いは
発展を始める前にcircuit内でハドロンの波束を中心に作成することだ。ではどのように
行われるかというと、真空状態が基底状態で、このマッピング方法はすでに扱った。では、ハドロン
波束の準備は少し異なる。この真空上で、隣接サイト上にフェルミオンと反フェルミオンのペアを作成することでハドロンが励起される。
異なる位置にそのようなハドロンの重ね合わせを準備することで、任意の波
束を準備できる。著者らは発展を観察するためにcircuitの中央に波束を中心に配置した。
境界を超えないようにするためだ。しかし、ノイズの多いqpuで作業する際のポイントは
circuit depthを管理可能に保つことだ。これを実現するために、SC adapt vqeプロトコルは対称性と
長さスケールの階層を使用して、状態準備のための低深度Quantum circuitを決定する。このアイデアは
より少ないパラメータ数のアンザッツを作成し、より浅い深さにつながるというものだ。詳細は
もちろん論文に記載されているので、ぜひ確認してほしい。では結果を見てみよう。この実験は
IBM Quantum Heronデバイスで実行され、いくつかの異なる種類のエラー緩和と抑制が実装された。
最近の技術であるオペレーターデコヒーレンス再規格化、ダイナミカルデカップリング、ゼロノイズ
外挿、ポーリーtwirlingなどが含まれる。ではデータを解釈してみよう。波束の伝播を観測するために実際に
測定する観測量はカイラル凝縮と呼ばれるもので、少し抽象的だが、
基本的にハドロンの超流体相だ。ここの実験実行に指定されたサイトに中心を置く波束が見える。
色はカイラル凝縮に対応している。
左側はシミュレーターからのエラーフリーの結果を示し、右側はIBM Quantum
コンピューターTorinoからの結果を示している。対称性により理想的にはこれらは互いに鏡像になるはずなので、いくつかの
不完全さがあることがわかる。この縦軸のy軸は以前に
測定した時間のチャンクに対応している。では、データの最初と最後の時間ステップを横断する水平カットを取って
波束に何が起こるか見てみよう。t=1のオレンジ色は
このカットに対応しており、カイラル凝縮が狭く局在しているのがわかる。また比較のために行われた
シミュレーションとも非常によく一致している。しかしt=14ではずっと広がっており、より
局在していない。シミュレーターとの比較は完璧ではないかもしれないが、理論とデータの間に非常に良い一致が明らかに見られる。
これは心強い。結論として、これは量子コンピューターに適用するとは最初は思わないかもしれない種類のシミュレーション作業のとても良い例だ。
しかし実際にできるし、機能する。完璧ではないが、素粒子物理学の
専門家でなくても、量子コンピューターが波束の外向き伝播を精度よく予測していることはわかる。
これはまさに期待される結果だ。この分野での将来の研究が続き、高エネルギー物理学者が
Quantum Computingを研究フローに組み込む方法を見つけ続けることを願っている。目標は理論的な問題をより正確に解決し、
古典的には解決できない問題を解き、実験を使って理論を受け入れるか拒否して新しい
物理学を発見することだ。改良された検出器を構築し、最も基本的なレベルでの自然のより深い理解につなげる。
次の例は最適化に焦点を当て、偏向場
デジタル化カウンター断熱Quantum最適化と呼ばれる論文への深い掘り下げになる。これはkipu quantumチームのメンバーと
スペインのバスク大学によって行われた。以前と同様に
定義の説明から始める。最初はカウンター断熱で、これはプロセスがどれだけ速く発生するかに関わらず、システムが経験する非断熱的
効果を抑制する発展の一種だ。前のエピソードの断熱定理を思い出してほしい。
システムが基底状態にとどまるためには、通常非常にゆっくりと発展させる必要がある。
これは大きな問題だ。ゆっくり発展させるほど、エラーが発生する時間が
増えるからだ。CDと略されることが多いカウンター断熱駆動は、これに対処することを目的として
望ましくない励起を打ち消す項を追加する。ここでの主なアイデアは実験全体を高速化し、
望まない遷移につながる可能性のある励起を抑制することでQuantum circuit depthを削減することだ。
では、偏向場とは何かについて話そう。vqeのような反復アルゴリズムは古典的なパラメータを
これらの状態に取り込み、古典的なオプティマイザーを使って多次元パラメータ空間を探索し、
固定ハミルトニアンの最小期待値をもたらすセットを見つける。この場合、代わりにハミルトニアンを毎回変化させ、
既知のケースから関心のあるケースへ断熱的に移行する。しかし、古典的なパラメータが
渡されず、変分波動関数もない場合、ハミルトニアンへの一回のパスから次のパスへどのように状態を更新するのか？では
ハミルトニアンにバイアス項を加える。前回の実行で得られた最低エネルギー状態に対して、その状態を優先するような項を
ハミルトニアンに加えるわけだ。では、なぜこの実験が
興味深いのか。まず、これは他の最適化問題にも広く応用できる新しいアプローチだ。
今回はイジングスピングラス問題に適用されている。先述の通り、多くの組み合わせ
最適化問題はイジングハミルトニアンの低エネルギー状態を求める問題として再定式化できる。イジング
モデルとは、配列上に分布した微視的スピンの集まりだ。このモデルはスピングラスの記述に使える。スピングラスとは
磁化が無秩序な状態、つまり配列内の小さな磁気モーメントがランダムな方向を向いている状態のことだ。
なぜこれがうまくいくと考えたのか。変分アルゴリズムに典型的な二つの問題にどう対処しているかは、
論文の定義を説明したときに既に触れた。要約すると、彼らが提案するアルゴリズムは
発展の速度を上げてcircuit depthを削減しつつ、非断熱遷移も抑制する。
さらに、Barren
plateauや局所最小値への収束という問題を引き起こしうる古典的最適化ルーティンに一切依存しない。最後に、著者たちは問題の
ハミルトニアン内の相互作用を実際のQPUのハードウェア接続性に合わせることにも注意を払っている。これは常に非常に重要な点だ。では、どのように動作するのか。
先述の通り、反復的な量子アルゴリズムでよく見られるような古典的オプティマイザーはここでは使用していない。
代わりに、各反復の解を次の反復の入力として与えることで、バイアス場デジタイズド
量子最適化アルゴリズムが基底状態を段階的に精緻化し、
最終的な発展状態に近づけていく。カウンター断熱プロトコルと組み合わせることで、短い深さの量子
circuitでもノイズの多いハードウェア上でスムーズに動作させることができる。実験が実施された際、著者たちは
127 qubit IBM量子コンピューターBrisbaneでアルゴリズムを実行することを選んだ。著者はここで
最近傍のランダム生成スピングラスインスタンスに対する最適化アルゴリズムのeth化を示した。
100 qubitを超えるもので、DCQとBF DCQの理想的なシミュレーション結果を比較し、
実験結果も示している。また、参考としてgoubiという古典的ソルバーの結果も示している。
たった10回の反復で、BF DCQはDCQと比べて
劇的な改善をもたらす。実験結果はノイズのため理想的な結果とは多少異なるが、それでも
理想的なDCQより優れた性能を示している。これは、量子最適化の分野でまだ多くの
優れた進展が続いていることを示しており、100 qubitを超えるスケールで良好な結果が報告されているのは
初めてのことの一つだ。最後に、mRNA構造予測を探求した非常に興味深い論文を紹介する。
madna Pharmaceuticalsの研究者たちによるもので、「ユーティリティスケール量子コンピューターを使用したmRNA二次構造予測」と題されている。
まず、私のように数年間生物学の授業を受けていない人のために、
mRNAについておさらいしよう。メッセンジャーRNAはタンパク質合成に関わるRNAの一種だ。
基本的にDNAが与える命令を読み取る。mRNAの二次構造とは、鎖がどのように折り畳まれているかのことで、
RNA二次構造予測問題とは、最も安定した塩基配列の折り畳みを見つける問題だ。
DNAとRNAを構成するヌクレオチドの塩基、つまりC、G、U、Aがそれに当たる。
この画像はmRNAに見られる一般的な折り畳み構造のいくつかを示している。ここで各色はそれぞれ異なる
二次構造を示しているが、ある構造が他の構造より好ましい理由となる正確な特性は
まだよく理解されていない。できることは、どの構造が非折り畳み状態と比べて最も低い自由エネルギーを持つかを
見つけることだけだ。そこで量子コンピューターが登場する。では、mRNA二次構造はなぜ
重要なのか。その正確な予測はDNAや遺伝子の理解だけでなく、
新型コロナウイルスワクチンのようなRNAベースの治療薬の設計にも非常に重要だ。この論文のアプローチが
うまくいくと信じる理由がある。なぜなら、これは古典的コンピューターにとって長年にわたり手強い最適化問題として知られてきた。
膨大な数の可能な構成があるためで、一部の構成については実際にNP完全問題であることが知られている。
しかし量子コンピューター上では、二次構造予測を
二値最適化問題として定式化できる。これは扱い方が分かっている問題だ。さらに、文献の中で既に
小規模な量子デバイスや量子シミュレーターでRNA予測が正確にできるという証拠がある。当然の疑問は、
より大規模なハードウェアでも機能するかということだ。実験は条件付きバリュー
アット・リスク変分量子固有値ソルバー（CVaR-VQE）と呼ばれる手法を使って行われる。これは従来のVQEアルゴリズムの改良版で、
より良い収束が期待できる。このプロットは42
ヌクレオチドの測定サンプルビット列の確率分布と対応するエネルギーを示している。
80 qubitのインスタンスだ。ビット列はヌクレオチドの対を表している。
最低エネルギーのビット列のエネルギー値が-140であることを示しており、これは
比較用の古典的ソルバーが見つけた最低エネルギーのビット列と一致する。素晴らしい結果だ。これがそのヌクレオチド鎖の最適な折り畳み
構造で、ハードウェアが最低エネルギーのビット列に基づいて
見つけたものだ。以上でこのエピソードの結論に達した。私の目的はさまざまな研究論文の
詳細で圧倒することではなかった。単に、現在この分野の最先端の研究がどのようなものかを理解するための十分なコンテキストを提供したかっただけだ。
これがみんなの頭の中で何かのきっかけになり、他の人たちがどのように問題にアプローチしているかを見ることで
繋がりを見出し、これまで挑戦しなかったような新しい量子実験を試みる
自信を持てるようになることを願っている。まあ、うまくいかないものもあるかもしれないが、
それで構わない。それが研究というものだ。今後は、私たちが興味を持つ問題の種類が
方法論別または主題別にグループ化できることを覚えておいてほしい。そして短期的に最も有望だと考えるものを
まとめた。量子コンピューティングがあらゆることに適しているわけではないことを覚えておいてほしい。これはまさに
古典的コンピューティングがいかに優れているかを証明している。量子コンピューティングを
ある問題に適用できると思っても、面白い結果が得られるとは限らない。残念ながら、スケーリングを考慮する必要がある。circuit
depthは諸刃の剣だ。古典的コンピューターではできない興味深い作業をするには十分大きくする必要があるが、
今はハードウェアのノイズのせいで大きくしすぎるとフィデリティが
低下してしまう。ちょうどいいスイートスポットを見つけることが重要で、それが動く目標であることも知っておく必要がある。次のエピソードまでの間に少し時間を取って、
これまでに遭遇した問題と、ここまで学んだことでどのようにアプローチしたいかについて真剣に考えてみてほしい。
クリエイティブになって、自分を制限しないでほしい。アイデアがあれば、たとえちょっと突拍子もないと思っても、
下のコメントで教えてほしい。見てくれてありがとう。また次回会おう。